Welcome to "Ear Biscuits"
the podcast where two lifelong
friends talk about life
for a long time.
I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we are hearing your voices.
Because you called, and
you answered the question,
we want to hear your bad
neighbors/roommate horror stories.
Give us a call
and share your story at 1-888-EARPOD1.
Yeah.
You know, I've had some neighbors.
I have neighbors.
In the past, on this show,
you have discussed some,
you got into some thickness
with your neighbors.
You got into the deep end of-
Yes.
Strife.
We will not recount that in detail.
But yes, when I moved
into my current home,
my neighbor, that was really
my only neighbor that we like,
you know, had contact with,
like physical contact.
Like, we shared a fence with them.
Your lands had contact.
The way that
my house is situated,
they're really the only neighbor
that you can really like,
have a fence with and stuff.
But anyway, yeah, we had a
tree dispute, a bush dispute.
There was a bunch of arguing
that went back and forth.
Because you basically planted
a palm tree on their land,
but right next to your driveway.
Yeah, after we talked about cutting down a
bush that was theirs.
Anyway, we had coffee and
we straightened it out,
and now we give each
other Christmas gifts.
So what is the long term takeaway?
It's been so long since that,
like, is it that you buy
'em a bottle of wine-
Well, what I tell people on the reg
when they begin telling
me their neighbor stories,
is I say, you gotta
nip that neighbor situation
in the bud.
Yep.
Because you cannot abide
in this way where you've
got some ongoing dispute.
Life is too short to be
in an ongoing dispute
with your neighbor.
Even if what they are saying and doing,
in my case, I thought
that, is unreasonable.
I was like, I don't care
how unreasonable this is.
I don't care who's right and who's wrong.
In my mind, you were
wrong, but keep going.
Oh, you love to throw me under the bus.
I was not wrong by a long shot.
But that was my takeaway,
it was pretty simple.
But the point being that
it doesn't matter who's
right or who's wrong.
It really doesn't matter.
I hear that.
Reconciliation is the
most important thing.
That's the right that you're looking for
when you're in a neighbor situation.
Now somebody might be
unwilling to compromise,
but as I told you in the previous story,
which has been years now,
when I sat down at a coffee
shop with my neighbor,
he immediately began to weep.
That's right.
Because he knew that he was in the wrong.
Okay, yeah, I've forgotten that part.
Yeah, so thanks a lot, Link.
When the person's crying,
that's wow, you broke him.
You didn't cry.
No, I didn't.
Ha!
I had I nothing to cry about.
Yeah, well, you talk
about nipping in the bud,
but to me, just to skip to
like the final analysis here,
if you have any opportunity to like,
build some positive rapport
with a neighbor, do it.
That's why when people
move in next to you,
you give 'em cookies, you
welcome to the neighborhood,
you give 'em a little
welcome package or something.
You introduce yourself.
Then you don't have to worry about
when are we gonna meet?
What circumstances are
we gonna meet under?
And is it gonna be when
I have to confront 'em
about something like
these voicemails we got?
Yeah. Or like, you're, oh,
I'm doing some work on my house
and they're a nosy neighbor,
and they're gonna come over to see if I
pulled the right permits
and stuff, you know?
That happens all the time in California.
Yeah, it happened with us.
We never knew which neighbor it was.
We ended up having to like
spend thousands of dollars
doing stuff we didn't plan on doing.
But you have a good situation
in your neighborhood.
I do. My cul-de-sac,
right there, all around the end,
we all know each other
and party together a
couple of times a year.
And we've got-
Sometimes a little too hard, I heard.
Yep, Christy's on a text thread
with some of those people.
I'm not on that text thread.
That's where I draw the line.
You can get hammered
in a cul-de-sac though.
Oh man, yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
There's only one way out.
Yeah, right.
It's like, it's really hard to get hurt.
Like it's really hard to get
run over in a cul-de-sac.
Yeah, that's right.
You know, 'cause it's
just like, it's just,
well, it's just the end of the road.
So you don't get hammered by a car.
I'm just saying.
You can get hammered.
A cul-de-sac, a place
where a road terminates,
surrounded by homes,
it just feels like a place that
you can just lose yourself,
you know?
Oh yeah.
Let it all hang out.
We did man.
You can't do that on a thoroughfare,
you know what I'm saying?
Nope.
You gotta do that in a place where,
listen, you saw this
and if you're gonna
tell somebody about it,
we're not gonna let you leave.
And we can all keep you here
because it's just one way out.
Yep.
It's about barricading.
If you live on a highway,
you can't get away with anything.
And then the cul-de-sac then it extends,
it curves around and then
extends to the main road.
So like, one of the things we
discussed at our last party
was how, this was not me talking either,
it seems like something
I would say in a group
to see how everybody reacted.
But one of my neighbors said,
"Yeah, we're in the balls of the street.
And then you kinda drive
down the shaft of the street
to get out to the main thoroughfare."
Those are pretty little balls
if you go those proportions.
Well it's basic,
it's just the cul-de-sac is a nut sack.
I understand the analogy.
I'm just saying that if I
were to take an overhead view
of your street, knowing
about how long it is.
The balls are proportionately small.
It's very cold in that cul-de-sac,
if you know what I'm saying.
Cold sack.
It's very cold.
That's why it's called that.
A cold sack.
Oh.
It's very shriveled
at the end.
You figured it out.
Yeah, I got a good.
You live at the shriveled
small end of the sack.
With my neighbors.
There was this whole thing about
my window from my shower,
giving me a vantage point to my neighbors,
which then I talked to 'em about it.
And it's like, I wanna
make a video about this.
They were super cool about it, you know.
They've since put up a fence
that then kind of makes it
a little more difficult for
me to see them drive to work.
They were super cool about it,
and since then they
have put up a barricade.
On the other side, we got new neighbors
and they're below me,
and there's that wall.
This is the guy that threw you
something off his grill.
No, no, no, that's the guy,
that's my backside neighbor.
I'm talking about my other side neighbor.
My backside neighbor,
I saw him on a walk
with the dogs a week ago
and I was like, hey, I'm Link,
I'm your neighbor up there.
And he was like, "Oh yeah,"
and he made the motion.
He's like, I threw it.
Of throwing the meat.
What did he throw? What kind of meat?
Like a hero meat on a shish kabob.
He took it off the-
A morsel.
A morsel, he took like a handful-
I threw the morsel.
Yeah, so he made the throwing motion.
This is the morsel motion.
He was like, oh yeah.
He was like, "Next time, come on down."
Oh, he was baiting you.
And I, yeah, and I remember his name now.
That's the other thing,
write down your neighbor's names.
Like I put in my phone, person's name,
and then I put neighbor.
So then when I can't
remember my neighbor's name,
I just search my address
book for neighbor.
And it's like, all my neighbors
from all the years come up.
You gotta make a good,
you gotta start on a positive foot
because inevitably there
will be conflict, as we see.
And with my new side neighbor,
there's that cinder block wall.
Walls are trouble, 'cause who owns them?
I own the wall.
Eh, but how do you really know?
Because I do.
And then I look over the wall-
They probably think the same thing.
And they've done all types of landscaping
once they moved in,
including planting trees,
that line the wall on their side
so they don't have to look
at the backside of my wall.
They can look at the trees they planted.
Because it's cinder block.
Christy wasn't happy
with what they planted.
I wish they would've asked me
what type of thing to plant.
I could've helped them come
up with something better.
And I'm like, well, the
only thing I'm worried about
is the fact that these
trees that they planted-
Are gonna grow.
Are gonna keep going
up and up and up.
And when I sit at my dining room table
and I look out that side window,
I can see a little bit of the mountains.
And I don't wanna see a
point blank range tree.
What, is it like those very
typical, like California,
like, they're gonna get really tall
and they look like they
might be evergreen.
Like bushes that just
keep going straight up.
It's a smaller,
I would call it, it's a tree,
but it kind of has a-
A bush like quality?
A bush like quality.
But I could already tell
when they first planted it,
I was like, there's a few that are higher.
And like, I'm sitting there
looking out my window
and my vantage point of the mountain
is being threatened from a seated height
by these freshly planted tree things.
If you need somebody to come over
and like accidentally be like wielding,
what is it, a scythe?
A scythe, yeah.
In like, oh,
the tall guy came over-
A scythe.
The scythe. The tall guy came over-
Scythe Lord.
I could come over,
here, this is it.
This is the plan.
Halloween night, I make
a great grim Reaper.
I bring my scythe or scythe.
Scythe.
You know what I'm talking about.
And I'm just having a grand old time.
It's a cul-de-sac,
so I get a little hammered
and I start swinging that thing around
and I just cut the tops
of their bushes off.
And I do it every Halloween.
Oh-
It's a way
to keep it controlled.
I appreciate the offer,
but I've already taken care of it.
Oh, snap!
Yeah, it was under the cover of darkness.
Because it's on my,
like my side, there's the wall,
which is like four and a half feet tall,
maybe even five feet tall.
And then there's like another foot of tree
that's now on top of that.
And it's right there at my eye level,
my hand level, when I'm like.
Say if I had clippers in my hand,
like some sort of landscaping shears,
let's just say I did.
Let's just say it was dark.
Oh gosh.
And let's just say, from my side,
it's just right there conveniently,
snip, snip, snip, snip, snip.
From their side,
the top of those trees is probably
seven or eight feet.
Oh really?
Cause their plot is lower than mine.
So I tried to snip off every single one
in a very uneven, natural pattern.
Yeah, this is just nature taking-
So it doesn't just look like I just
went across the top,
like epic rap battle of
manliness opening scene.
Yeah.
So but I did that like six weeks ago.
I already have to do it again
under the cover of darkness.
You wanna come over?
We could get in ninja suits.
You are trimming your
neighbor's bushes at night.
Just to keep 'em at the right level.
I mean-
Yeah.
And they can't get any taller.
Well, you might be in some way,
you might be creating bonsai.
You know what I'm saying?
Like if you keep a tree from growing-
I thought you were gonna say-
Other things start happening.
No, that's not gonna happen.
Well, I thought you were gonna say,
maybe you're creating,
maybe you're doing your neighbor of favor,
which is how I am looking at it.
I can conveniently trim their tree.
Hold on. Do you-
Without them even
having to pace somebody.
Do you hold, do you grasp the bush
and trim it so you keep
the trimmings on your side.
Hell yeah.
Wait, who do you think I am?
So all the evidence is on your side.
Oh yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And if, you know what,
if they happen to get curious
and notice and like maybe
I see 'em in passing
and they're asking about like-
These trees are supposed
to be 16 feet tall now.
If they ask me about it,
I'm gonna say, I don't know.
That would be a lie, but I will say that.
I'm going to lie.
I'm gonna say, I don't
know, but I haven't noticed,
maybe my landscapers are trimming that
just as a courtesy to you.
Well, you could say, I'm a sleep trimmer.
You know, it's like sleep walking-
I don't remember doing it,
but I might do it.
But I only trim bushes
while sleep walking.
It's-
Including my own.
I'm not, what I'm doing isn't right
and I'm not proud of it.
I don't know.
But I'm not-
It is against the law
probably, technically.
I'm not-
I don't think
you can touch your neighbor's
bush without consent.
Prepared to do anything else.
Like, I'm not prepared
to do the right thing,
which I don't even want
to know what that is.
But unless you want to tell me.
I mean, what's the right thing to do here?
Talk to my neighbor, Mr. F?
I mean-
We do know each other.
We're on a first name basis.
We met at a cul-de-sac party
right when they moved in.
And, but they really keep to themselves.
Okay. Have you looked at the bushes
from their perspective?
No. You want me to sneak
into their backyard
and look back up?
So it's the backyard?
It's the backyard.
Okay, okay, okay.
I don't think they would mind,
but I don't wanna take the risk
to ask them.
Okay,
this is what I would do if I were you.
I would get a selfie stick, okay.
Approximately 10 feet long.
You got to do this when
they're at daytime,
when they're not there.
And you put your phone on wide angle
and you stick it into their backyard
and get a look at what their perspective
of their bushes would be.
If you're not gonna be helpful-
I'm not kidding.
You're wasting my time.
I'm not kidding. That's step one.
So you actually can appreciate like,
oh yeah, totally fine.
If you get down there and you're like,
oh no, I'm ruining this
from their perspective,
which I don't think is the case.
I just think you gotta confirm
because then I do think you go to them.
And the fact that you've
been trimming already,
I'm just saying, if you
wanna do the right thing,
I'm not saying this is what you should do.
I'm saying, if you wanna
do the right thing,
I think the thing that I would do
is I would keep trimming
the bushes at night.
And it would probably
never become a thing.
Yeah.
Which is probably what you're gonna do.
But if you wanna do the right thing-
I'm a night bush boy.
I would go and I would say,
"Hey, I wanted to talk about your bushes.
You know, I feel like if we
just let them keep growing,
it's really gonna obstruct our view.
But my assumption is
that you guys don't really care
that they need to get taller than,
you know, the seven or
eight feet that they are
and kind of covering,
you know, I'm sure it's
just kind of beautifying
your experience in the back.
And you're not looking
at a cinder block wall.
You know, I didn't wanna
come over without asking.
So I did stick a selfie
stick over the fence.
And I know what it looks
like for your perspective,
in my mind, it looks great."
I-
Here's the video.
I think the chance is,
the only risk is that they
want it to grow taller
'cause from their vantage point,
they wanna block something
that is currently being seen.
You won't know what that is
unless you do the selfie stick method.
The key to winning an argument
is knowing everything that
the opponent is thinking.
Everything about their perspective.
You basically need to steel man
their argument, not straw man.
I know what I'm gonna do.
Bushman.
I'm gonna pick a time
when they're not there.
I'm going to throw a ball into their pool.
Oh.
In the backyard.
I'm gonna go, I'm gonna knock on the door.
When nobody comes to the door,
I'm gonna go into the
backyard of their house
and I'm gonna retrieve my ball.
Okay.
And while I do,
I will have the perfect vantage point,
even if they have cameras.
I was just getting my ball.
I was just getting my ball
and looking at your-
We saw you on camera,
aiming for our pool.
Because the bushes are too short
and they didn't block it.
They're gonna get you on camera.
That's the weakness in this plan.
I'm gonna get Lando to do it.
Ah, yes.
I'm gonna bring a child into this.
Yeah, our child is strange.
He jus loves to throw balls.
You wanna come over and do it?
No, you're too tall.
And then I'm gonna look and I'll know.
If there's something to block
and then if there's nothing
to block vertically,
then I'm just gonna keep night trimming.
What about your pool equipment?
Do you think that they're
blocking your pool equipment?
Yeah, but that's not an issue.
It's lower.
'Cause that's
below the wall.
It's lower.
But yeah. So I'm just gonna do
'em what I think is a favor.
And if I get backed into a
corner and I have to admit to it,
I'm just gonna, you know,
I'm gonna work my Link charm, you know.
I've never been punched in the face.
Well, I-
And I've deserved it a lot.
One small thing, the way
I kind of relate to this.
Let me know, #EarBiscuits, by the way.
You know, we've kind of like-
Or 1- 888- EarPod1.
Yes, we know.
Please let me know.
I've kind of landscaped
a little area there
next to my home.
Yes.
And I have crossed the boundary.
It's not your land.
I'm 10 feet into the next yard,
but it's an empty lot.
And we're just like,
eh, nobody lives there.
That's fine.
You did the right thing.
But one of the things,
and there's also like,
after a while it becomes my land.
I don't know how many
years it is in California.
But after a while I get it,
just because I've staked my claim.
Imminent domain. That's not-
But we have a little bench
that we've set up there
to kind of like, I'll go out there and,
have you sat on my bench?
I haven't.
Yeah, we have a little
bench over there now that
you can watch the sunset.
You can look over the whole neighborhood.
It's wonderful.
Have a glass of wine.
Haven't done that yet,
but I've definitely thought about it.
But there-
Keep a box of wine
underneath the bench.
There's one tree.
Oh yep.
About two,
like two roads away.
That's a pretty large
tree. It's pretty tall.
You know what? Say no more.
Yes, I will help you chop down this tree.
No, no, this is my plan.
So I think that it may be maxed out.
I have no morality when it comes to
landscaping other people's lawns.
Well, trees don't have souls.
I think that this tree
might be done growing,
but I'm keeping a really close eye on it.
And if it isn't done growing,
it could obstruct my view of the sunset.
Here's my plan.
Because I'm sure these people
are proud of this tree.
I'm gonna get into archery.
Okay.
And I'm going to poison the tip of a arrow
with some sort of like a beetle colony.
Oh no, Rhett,
that's horrible.
I'm gonna put like a
egg sack of a tree killing beetle.
And I'm gonna aim at the
trunk from a distance,
in the car-
Think about all the
damage you're gonna do when you miss?
No, no. Um, first of all-
beetle investigation.
I'm gonna train for months.
I get one shot at this.
And I'm gonna have, at the cover of night,
I will be dressed as the Grim Reaper
and I will have on night vision goggles
and I'll be sitting on my bench.
And I will aim at the trunk of that tree.
It'll be probably a crossbow
because you can aim a little
bit better with a crossbow
with a beetle colony on the tip,
goes right into the,
they'll never know what hit the tree.
'Cause it'll also be a-
Disintegrated arrow.
A disintegrating arrow.
Right, don't forget that.
An arrow that biodegrades.
Quickly, very quickly.
No.
On impact.
It's a wooden arrow that the beetles eat.
It's the first thing the larva eat
when they come to life.
Just make the arrow look like a tree limp.
Even better idea.
Right.
We're full-
It'll be so high up.
It's gonna something
like 60 feet in the air.
Not a good idea.
I don't know what happened in that tree,
but when it finally fell,
there was an arrow in it.
What's the problem part
of the tree though?
The top.
Well, here's what I think you should do.
It's not a problem yet,
but it might be one day.
Yeah. What I think you should do is
you should approach those people and say,
I would like, you explain
your situation, and you say,
"I would like to pay for
your trees to be trimmed.
That's something that we all have to do.
I would like to cover the cost of that
whenever you do it next time
and all I'm asking is that
they also top off the tree,"
which is something that they do.
It helps 'em keep the trees healthy.
A lot of trees in our
area., if you'll notice,
especially like those pines-
They got bad tops.
They top 'em off.
So they have a blunt
top because when you're,
when you're there, when it's in your yard,
that has no impact on you.
Right.
You can't see the top.
But I think it
helps the health of the tree.
I'm no arborist,
but it really helps your view.
And there's places like
that, that I've thought of.
I thought about going
all the way through like
miles from my house
and like tracking down
the owners of these trees
and just like throwing money at 'em
so I can top their trees.
Well.
Just cut the tops right off.
We did cut down a few trees in that
lot that we don't own.
Not because of the view-
That's called brush clearance.
That's a favor. You did 'em a favor.
It was because we had
been told by somebody
who knew what they were talking about.
It wasn't like an arborist,
but he was like someone who
had a good friend who was one.
Okay.
And he was like those trees are-
Friend of the trees.
Those trees are about to
fall into the neighbor's yard
and also it's a fire hazard.
And so we were like, yeah.
And we paid for it out of our pocket.
And we tried to contact
the owner of the lot
and he didn't he get back to us
and so we just cut 'em down.
All right. Yeah, that's another dilemma.
Let us let us know.
I like the fact that
we have this voicemail
and of course, now we're gonna
listen to your voicemails
after we talk about our
new freaking party game.
Yeah.
We're Still Good.
Now, you know, we're really
into games, especially me.
I have a game night that,
actually haven't restituted it yet, but-
But now's the time.
Pre-pandemic.
To promote our game to our friends.
I love getting people together.
And I love games.
You know, Cards Against Humanity
kinda started this whole
craze of the party game
that's not a complicated
board game with rules
and everybody's sitting around a table.
It's not a tabletop game.
It's a party game that's
based on cards and tokens.
And it's also just based on
taking a horrible scenario,
which is actually just
ridiculously hilarious,
but a negative scenario
and putting a positive spin on it.
And then picking the best positive spin.
There's some cards
and it's not completely
just a creative exercise.
You get to like fill in the blank.
It's incredibly fun.
We've played it a couple of times.
There's two stages to each round,
which makes it more fun
and, I think, original.
You can play in teams. You
can play as an individual.
You take a scenario that has a blank.
And then everybody submits
one of the cards that they
have acquired randomly.
And then the judge in each round
decides to fill in the blank
and make like this crazy
negative situation.
Right.
And then everybody for the
second phase of this round
then has to put a positive
spin on this crazy scenario
once the blank has been filled in.
And the judge picks the
one, they like the best.
It could be like-
It's fun.
The card could be,
you just found out that in
the middle of the night,
your neighbor is blank
and you might get a card that says
shooting a beetle infested
arrow at your biggest tree.
And you're like, we're still good.
Yeah because-
I hated that tree.
Because I love Beatles,
my favorite band.
You see, the Beatles are my favorite band,
that would be a funny.
That would, yeah.
That's an example of one
that might be chosen.
So, We're Still Good.
Just holding the box,
I wish I had it right now.
It's satisfying.
You can imagine what it feels like.
It's satisfying to say there's a physical
game that we have
developed that you can own
and increase your mythicality.
And if you get drunk in a
cul-de-sac on a regular basis,
it'd be real fun in a
cul-de-sac while hammered.
Let's listen to a voicemail.
Yes.
Hi, there guys.
I have a very interesting, not roommate,
but a neighbor story.
So I live in an apartment,
college apartment.
I'll try to make this pretty quick,
heard a loud noise
outside, looked outside,
someone smashed one of our lights.
The girl across from me was confused.
We both confused, go back inside,
and my roommates then come
home and they're like,
"Hey, someone's peeing in the hallway."
So they're taking a piss in the hallway.
I finally I'm like, okay, this is enough.
I come out there and I'm like,
"Hey man, what are you doing?"
Immediately whips around at me,
least pulls his pants up beforehand.
Good.
Throws his shirt off as quick as he can.
And pretty dang quickly is in my face,
ready to fight me.
Definitely much taller than
me, much more built than me,
and I'm like, oh man, I
didn't wanna fight you.
I just don't want you
taking a pee in the hallway
that I live in-
Reasonable.
For obvious reasons.
So, and so happens,
a bunch of people come out
and dissolve the issue
and you know, it ended up
working out in the end.
I didn't have to fight to Jay Buckley,
but pretty dang interesting story.
And yeah, they were very
interesting to live with
for the rest of that time. Thanks guys.
Yeah, 'cause after that,
that big guy with his shirt on or off,
you never know what you're gonna get,
he's still around.
Obviously, he was under
the influence of something.
If you're gonna pee in a hallway,
it can't be your own.
It can't be your own.
I mean, just to get that out of the way.
There are circumstances in
which pissing in a hallway
is probably permitted,
you know what I'm saying.
Like, I don't know.
I'm just saying,
let's just say-
Yeah, tell me why.
This scenario-
I'm waiting.
Okay, might be that
you're being held up.
You know, like maybe you're
being held up at gunpoint.
Okay, you're being held hostage
in a hallway.
And you never know-
And you have to pee.
Well, you-
After a while.
No, I'm saying that,
like, a lot of people,
if you point a gun at them, they pee.
You know what I'm saying?
I've never had that happen to me.
I don't know what I would do.
Being stuck in an elevator.
You're gonna pee in the corner.
Even though, you know,
you gotta stay there.
And if you can get your tally whacker out
the split of the elevator,
it'd be better to pee into the hall.
This is a perfect situation.
Then it starts going.
And that thing clamps down.
No, you get everyone else in the elevator,
cause assuming you're not alone,
to hold it open,
just big enough for your tally whacker
to go out into the hall and pee
'cause that's what they want.
They don't want you
peeing inside the elevator
that we're all stuck in.
No pee out into the hallway.
That would be acceptable.
Who transferred the terminology
of tally whacker to you?
Because I got it from you
when we were like kids.
That's what my parents called it
when they were growing up.
Tally whacker.
Yeah, tally whacker.
They didn't, I'm saying-
So at tally is when you're like-
When they were growing up.
They didn't call it a
tally whacker for me.
We called it dingdong.
Okay. Yeah.
It was always very confusing
'cause I always thought
somebody was at the door.
But tally whacker is what they called it
in South Georgia way back in the day.
And you know what I called it
from when I like stayed at
like preschool, pre preschool.
As early as I can remember.
Yeah, when you say it,
I'm gonna remember it.
A pee toe.
Yeah. That okay, why?
Somebody referred to it as that
and it kind of makes sense.
You know, you're a preschooler.
You don't have a third leg.
You just have a 11th toe.
That you pee out of.
But it sounds so much like something else.
Pee toe. I mean, it's so close too.
I didn't know that.
I mean P double E T O E.
I mean, it's like if you know, you know,
but if you don't, yeah,
you might think it's peedo.
I understand that now, but I didn't then.
Thank God, I didn't know what that was.
But this back to the situation
and this is ridiculous.
First of all, when you
approach somebody doing this,
that's a delicate situation
'cause there's always like, hey buddy.
Like you-
Hey.
It's like, you gotta say something.
Approach with a bucket and
just start catching it.
Cause I think there's-
Can I help?
Some people are like, but
what, what the hell dude?
He took his shirt off immediately.
I mean that is what you're
afraid is gonna happen.
Well, he was an angry drunk.
But why is he taking it,
he don't wanna get blood on his shirt?
An angry sloppy drunk.
That's an intimidation move there.
It's like, not only am I
gonna bow up and fight you,
I'm gonna take my shirt off first
because all of the blood spatter from me
just whooping you
is not gonna get on my shirt, Jack.
Yeah, I mean-
I'm glad it was diffused,
but yeah, you never know
what people are gonna do
and you never know how
they're gonna respond
if they're peeing in their own hallway.
It's just, you know,
just chalk it up to having
to clean it up later.
I peed in a trashcan one time when I-
Sleep walking?
I was barely awake, yeah.
Okay.
And I was also a child.
So I had some roommates
in my first apartment ever
that I had known from my
previous year of college.
I met them on campus and
we were good buddies.
We had hung out outside
of class plenty of times.
These seemed like normal
well adjusted people.
Okay.
They ended up believing that
our first floor apartment
was haunted.
Okay.
Because they heard footsteps.
Okay, it's a college apartment complex.
And there were plenty of
people up walking around.
But they might have been ghost footstep.
During the middle of the night.
Does sound different, right?
Partying or otherwise.
And this escalated to a point where I
came home after a weekend
away with my now husband
and they had drawn charcoal
pentagrams on the walls
and the doors
because they quote, felt
a presence, unquote.
Well.
So that was,
yeah, that was my first
roommate experience.
And my last.
No more roommates after that.
You kinda gotta approach this with
a little bit of sensitivity
because this is,
I mean, this could be a
religious/spiritual exercise.
This could be a personal belief set.
And I'm not wanna say that,
I'm not ready to say
that ghosts don't exist
and I'm not ready to say what
pentagrams will do to them.
But I do understand that if it was me,
I would be like,
I don't consider pentagrams to be like
a part of my feng shui,
you know what I'm saying?
You could go like the decorative route.
Yeah, it's like, let's go,
we need to go in a different
non pentagram direction.
Well, and maybe-
With the motif here.
And how about, let's just
not do charcoal on the walls.
Charcoal is semi-permanent
or is totally washable?
If it was sharpie.
I think it depends on if we're
talking about an eggshell
or a flat paint.
Well, I got another podcast for that.
Which I, listen to your dad talk.
My wife and I were listening to
dispatchers from Myrtle Beach.
And he was talking about
eggshell and satin,
you know, and gloss and-
Yeah.
I was completely on
Charles' side about this,
about how you want to use
an eggshell in a bathroom
and not a gloss
and Jessie who's, you
know, she's a designer,
she has these opinions and she was like,
"Oh, I like to do a gloss
in the bathroom."
I was like, "Ah, too shiny."
Shows too many imperfections.
And that eggshell-
You're not gonna
be happy with it.
Yeah, so anyway, I do defer-
She's got beef with my dad?
They're gonna have to face off.
No, she didn't completely
disagree with him,
but she's just done
in a well constructed bathroom
where the sheet rock work
was high quality,
sometimes that extra sheen gives a,
you know, makes you feel
a little more alive.
Well, my dad has gotten
good over the years of
navigating women in his life
who disagree with him.
Yeah, yeah. It's his job.
You know,
he learns to be quiet.
And I'm not talking about clients.
I'm just talking about just relationships.
That's what he told me.
He learned to keep his mouth shut.
So he'd probably just let her win.
Most things resolve themselves
without saying anything.
That's what he's telling me.
Yeah, this is a tough one because,
yeah, I mean, first of all,
depending on your, you know,
your religious disposition,
it seems like a pentagram might invite,
if you're already believing
in the supernatural
of some sort-
Not ghosts, but demons.
Yeah, with the pentagram,
you may be inviting
something more sinister
into the situation.
I don't know enough about it
to tell you one way or another,
but it seems like maybe it's like,
hey it, you know, how about
just do the cross on the,
let's do a cross on the door.
Right?
You know.
If there's a clash of
personal beliefs here,
then you gotta figure
out a way to work it.
I think you gotta, yeah,
you gotta figure out like,
what is the overall religious
disposition of the house?
We gotta be on the same team here
in order to deal with these
spirits in the way that
we think is going to be effective.
I don't know.
That kind of reminds me of the,
I don't remember many of
the details, but you know,
Kiko told us about the
story of the haunted.
Yeah, but they were,
everyone in the house was kind of
undeniably on the same page.
Like they, I mean, they-
Kind of in denial about it.
No, they all were like, yes,
something's going on here.
There was agreement actually,
from what I remember.
Yeah, huh.
I think you have to join,
if you want everyone to be
dealing with these spirits
in the same way,
you have to join a coven,
where you all think the same thing.
Or a Bible study.
You gotta pick your side and then you-
When you're talking about a roommate,
that's like, how do you, like,
she was trying to ascertain like,
is this person, do I
vibe with this person?
Or, I mean, the way she put it was like,
is this person like normal, you know?
She didn't say the word normal.
I can't remember what she said,
but you don't what I'm saying it.
So if you wanna like get at
somebody's like spiritual beliefs,
I mean, you can clash about anything
in a roommate situation,
but how do you ask that?
'Cause that's not a fair question
when you're trying to
find a roommate or is it?
Well, I think that-
Isn't that illegal?
To me, it probably is,
but to me the specific situation is
we believe there are spirits in this home
and we are taking the following actions,
which it's not like, hey, inside my room,
I've got some sage
and some other stuff that I'm doing.
Yeah, if it's-
Or even going around-
Communal areas-
Well even taking sage around like
the perimeter of your home,
or like that's not necessarily offensive,
but the pentagram, it's a decorative,
like you said, it's a decorative decision
that says something about this house.
And if that's not something
that everybody agrees with,
ah, we have a problem.
Yeah. And maybe you gotta
consult the spirits too.
So I live
on a ground floor apartment and above me,
there is a family with two
very, very rowdy children.
I work from home, which
is great. I love it.
But it is extremely
hard when there are two,
three to five year olds
running back and forth,
legitimately, all day,
from about 5:00 AM to
11 to 12 at night.
What?
They are running back
and forth all the time.
And it is distracting.
I've gotten used to it,
but when guests come over,
they're like, how do you sleep?
How do you exist in this?
And it's capitalism, baby.
But I was playing video games
one night on the Switch.
I was up, I was moving,
and they were playing
outside the apartment.
And again, I live on the ground floor
and they started banging
on the window going,
"Are you dancing?"
And it ruined my life.
So I now hate children
and I never wanna live in a
ground floor apartment again.
Are you dancing?
'Cause that's what we do
from 5:00 AM until 11:00 PM.
Man, give these kids a better bedtime.
That's tough, man.
When you've got people above you.
I mean, when we had our
apartment in college,
that was the last time I
lived with people above me.
And it's, boy that-
You had somebody above you
in the apartment that we moved into
when we first moved to California.
You weren't on the top floor.
That's true.
I was on the top floor.
That's right.
Out here.
I didn't have anybody above me.
I don't recall it being a problem.
That was-
I think it was a thicker-
It all depends on
the nature of the-
Building.
In LA, a lot of the apartment complexes
have concrete floors in between.
I don't know, maybe just because of like
earthquakes and stuff,
but it really doesn't
end up being a big deal.
Don't say the E word.
Oh, you think I'm gonna incite one?
Yeah.
But-
We're gonna have to put up,
what's the pentagram equivalent
for keeping earthquakes away?
I don't believe there is one.
If there was Christy would've found it.
You can shoot some like foam
into the ground or something.
Shock absorbers.
Yeah, this is so tough because I think-
People are protective of their kids.
You know, if you're trying
to talk to 'em about
their kids, it's like,
well, isn't, they're just a bundle of joy.
Well, it's very difficult
because in certain situations
it doesn't necessarily mean
that they're doing anything
that is abnormally loud.
If the floors are really thin-
Kids being kids, man.
But now these kids-
The core problem is just kids.
If the kids are maybe they're
training for something,
I don't know.
Maybe they're gonna be in
like the junior Olympics.
There's nothing you can do.
And like, if a kid asks
me, if I'm dancing,
you can't let that ruin your life.
You just can't.
You can't let anything a kid does, oh man.
I honestly don't know
what the solution is.
Yeah. We feel your pain.
Maybe we just need to acknowledge
how difficult this is.
It's like, I hear that
this is tough for you.
Thank you for sharing.
I'm sorry that you have
to put up with this.
I think I have a solution.
And I'm not saying this
is a fool proof solution,
but I honestly believe-
Which basically means
it's not
No, well,
fool proof means that they
would be quiet all of a sudden.
Foolproof would be, we
gotta get rid of these kids.
And that's not what I'm advocating.
If you have not yet had a conversation
with the people above you
about the nature of the noise,
you need to have a conversation.
I'm not gonna dictate what you should say,
but simply having a conversation
adds a new factor into the situation
from the parent's perspective,
which then is translated to
the children's perspective.
And that is, oh,
when you guys run around
the woman who lives below us hears it
and I can imagine that that's annoying.
So now I'm thinking about that.
But if this family is up there
just operating in complete ignorance
about the amount of noise they're making,
there's no buffer at all.
But if you know there's somebody below,
you'd be like, oh, okay,
you guys are running around at 5:00 AM.
Hey guys, remember
there's people below us.
It's not gonna change everything,
but it's gonna take the edge off.
Yeah. And I-
You gotta have
that conversation.
I think if there's
some sort of, well,
you take a gift basket up there
and it's got a toy for each kid.
And a big pair of really padded slippers.
Yeah.
For everyone.
Can you wear these big feet foot?
Yeah.
Big feet shoes.
Definitely a very quiet toys for the kids
'cause you don't wanna
shoot yourself in the foot
by giving him something loud.
But then you're like, it's
a gesture of positivity.
What's it called
when you give something nice to somebody?
I would've known before I got COVID brain.
This is the kind of thing
I can't remember anymore
when somebody, a peace offering.
You can't hide, yes,
you can't hide behind that
the rest of your life, man.
You're just getting stupid.
And that never happened to me before.
I'm telling you.
Okay.
Peace offering.
It's there. It just
takes longer to get to.
I'm rebuilding neural networks.
And then you just have
a little conversation.
But you have to say,
you're not asking for them
to be quiet at all times.
You're just asking for like,
I don't know, is it like,
you work at home.
It's really difficult.
If you figure out something
that you feel like
is a reasonable yet open ended request for
an awareness and a little sensitivity.
Yep.
It's tough, man. It is tough.
Hi, my name is Tanisha.
I live in Atlanta.
I've been listening to "Ear Biscuits"
and watching GMM since
you guys first started.
I have followed you guys across the US.
I love you guys. I love everybody.
You guys are awesome.
But-
I'm responding to the bad neighbor thing.
My bad neighbor experience,
I live in some apartments.
And I had a neighbor
who insisted on having
adult fun times.
Huh?
Very loudly in their living room.
That's fine except our
front doors are French doors
and they didn't have curtains.
So when I would walk to my apartment
and I had to pass their
apartment to get to my apartment,
I would get a show every evening.
Even though I didn't want that show,
I still got that show.
So one day I happened to mention to-
Every evening.
They got the show. Every freaking evening!
Well like, and not just through a window,
but through like two-
French doors.
Doors full of glass. Man!
To them, hey,
I got these really awesome
curtains on my front door.
And they were very offended that I
mentioned that to them
and told them, or kind of hinted at,
we don't wanna see your show every night.
And it was like for two
hours, which is amazing,
but it's an absolute no.
So anyway, that's my story.
They eventually moved out after a month,
a lot of people complained.
But that's my story. Love you guys.
Okay, before we into the solution
of what to do about this.
I just gotta figure this situation out.
We got a couple,
essentially they're exhibitionist, right?
Because you know that
somebody's watching you,
you know that you can be seen.
This isn't something that you,
oh, we didn't realize that
we were in the living room.
Every night for two hours.
Two hours.
And now, first of all,
two hours every night.
You know what? They need
to get a television.
What kind of medication is this guy on?
They need to get like
a laptop or something.
You need to start streaming
things, it's like-
Well, that's my theory
is that they were, okay.
So I think that-
Oh, oh,
they were streaming things.
I think this may have been a cam couple.
Okay.
And I think that
the living room provided the
best lighting and scenery,
which is an important choice
when you're making independent porn.
But curtains, she mentioned curtains.
But when you are making porn
and you're good at it and you know it,
and any dude who can go for two hours-
Not considerate.
I'm just saying-
You're not getting paid by your neighbors.
I know but I'm just saying,
it's part of the spirit of it.
If you're broadcasting it to
thousands of people at once,
well what does a couple
more neighbors matter?
I'm not saying I agree with it.
I'm trying to get inside
the the head space.
Yeah.
I'm just saying there's something,
these are professional-
Especially because-
Sex havers.
Multiple people
complained to the point
where they moved out.
It wasn't just her.
If you're having sex for two
hours every single night,
this is your job, you
know what I'm saying?
I don't think that-
It definitely makes me feel better.
I don't think that you can have a job
and then have sex for
two hours every night.
You'd be too bow-legged.
I mean, you could be a cowboy.
Depends on which one you are, I guess.
So, first of all,
I do think that's my assessment
of this situation is that
there was a webcam that you couldn't see.
So really, the thing that
you could have gotten them on
is a technicality about
operating a business in
the apartment complex.
That would've been the proper
way to account for that.
Man.
Now I gotta say,
I've stayed in a couple of apartments
or a couple of hotels in Manhattan,
where you get that situation where
you are now looking into
like an apartment complex
or a hotel across the way and-
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Gets dark
and some people close the curtains
and some people don't.
And there's been a number of times when,
not out of intention,
but just out of happenstance to be like,
oh, there's a couple
that looks like they might
be about to make love.
Yeah.
And I I've never seen anybody make love.
I think there was one time
I did see somebody making love
through one of those like sheer curtains
where you could sort of see bodies moving,
but it couldn't make out any details.
Are you getting it confused
with the time that you
and I both were like, what
are they doing over there?
And then we figured out
they were playing corn hole
inside their apartment.
Well, that was one of them.
That was just one instance,
which I'm just raising a question-
Which that was wild.
I'm raising a question right now.
And I have a feeling that we probably have
a difference of opinion on this.
No, I would look.
You would?
But I wouldn't talk
about it on this podcast.
But like, is it-
I don't wanna be judged for that.
I'm just asking the question.
If a couple is making love
and you can see it through a window
and it's obvious that they,
it's not like, oh, we
forgot to close the window,
you know?
Well,
I don't know how it would be obvious,
but I'm just being honest,
it's never happened.
But maybe I would look a little bit.
Well, there was one time that Jessie
and I were staying in hotel.
And my wife
likes to, you know, draw
the curtains, you know?
Yeah, okay. I don't.
And we were in New York, I think,
some place where there was
another building across the way.
And I was like, let's just leave 'em open
and give people a show.
I legitimately said that.
You said give them a show?
Give 'em a show.
You saw them.
No, I was like, if you
start screwing in a window,
not in a window, but like,
you start screwing in a
bedroom that has a window in-
Don't do it up against the window
'cause you don't want that thing
to fall out.
I'm just saying,
there was a part of me that I was like,
I feel like maybe-
Hell of a way to go though.
There's a part of me that's
a little exhibitionist
because I thought to myself,
it's fun to watch people have sex.
There's a reason that people watch porn.
It's fun to watch people having sex.
And if you can be a part of that
in a non-professional way,
but just sort of like,
oh, we forgot to close the window,
just every once in a while,
I think that's a beautiful
part of humanity.
But this situation
that this woman was
dealing with is different.
But you can't force it on people.
Like to me, it comes down to like,
this window needs to stay open because
I paid for this room with a view.
And I like to look at views
while I'm sorting the mail.
I do. It's part of it.
Like I don't look away from
Christy the whole time,
but I might glance away and say, wow.
I mean, I like-
Wow.
I like making love in places where I can-
The city that never sleeps.
I can see the view while it's happening.
You know, it's like,
it's fun.
Understood.
That's part of it.
I've never, so that's my main motivation.
And it's so far away from other people
that like-
They can't tell who you are.
You're not imposing.
They can look away. They
can draw their curtains.
They can-
What are their legal ramifications though?
But it's so far away that you're small.
Are there legal ramifications?
I mean, what about children watching?
Well, that's what I'm asking.
Is there, again-
I don't want no children watching.
Is there a law-
For the record.
Is there a law against
you know, open windows screwing?
That's a good question.
Like, is it okay?
Like, what if you did it
right up against the window?
What if you had your butt cheek spread
Is that wrong?
I mean, I'm not asking if it's wrong.
Is it illegal?
Is there a point in
which it becomes illegal?
How do I-
Because if you go to a park,
and pull your tally whacker out,
you'll get arrested for indecent exposure.
But if you're in the
privacy of your own home
and you pull your tally whacker out
and people can see you across the way.
Is it a crime to have sex
with the windows open?
Hey, I love the fact that we've got this.
Public sex laws in California.
Okay, that's where we're at.
We're in the liberalist of states.
Penal code,
6 47 A makes it a crime quote,
to engage in or to solicit
anyone to engage in-
Jenna's over here nodding her head like,
you already knew this or
you were just looking it up?
I just looked it up too. I was like.
Okay.
Engage in lewd
or dissolute conduct in any public place
or in any place open to the public
or exposed to public view.
You can't, well, okay.
I just said I was all
about committing a crime.
Cause you didn't think it was public sex
when it was in your private place.
But when the windows are open, it is.
Wow, what about New York though,
'cause that's where I do my public sex.
I know I do it only in Manhattan.
I don't do it in Los Angeles.
So I'm just gonna ask.
And for the record, I have not done it.
I've only had discussions.
If the FBI is listening to this,
because I know it would
immediately be a federal case,
if I was caught having sex in a window.
Is it a crime to have
sex in a car in New York?
Oh, is it?
You are charged with a misdemeanor.
Okay.
You're not going to go
to jail but-
I can handle a misdemeanor.
But you don't want to end up with
a criminal record for life.
Yeah, but in the job interview, it's like,
have you ever been arrested? Well-
I don't know why they're asking.
Let me tell you.
Car sex.
I had sex in a car.
Are you not gonna hire me because of that?
I had sex.
I put my butt cheeks right up
against a window in Manhattan.
That sounds-
What do I search,
law sex with curtains open NYC?
Sex in your own home laws.
Yeah, I feel like, man,
you should be able to do it.
Because it's not like people are like
up against the window where
their eyes taped open,
you know what I'm saying.
They've got the ability,
I think we should advocate
for this law to be changed
if it is indeed illegal to have sex
with the windows open in Manhattan.
I believe we should
advocate against this law.
I don't think this is the
hill I'm gonna die on.
No, I am moving to Manhattan.
I'm gonna be there long enough
to become a city council member
and this is my campaign.
Jenna, what'd you find?
I think there's a case
to argue in California,
'cause there's also the Peeping Tom Law
that it's illegal to
peek in a door, a window,
on a private property
without consent of the owner.
Peeping Tom Law.
It's illegal to peep in a what?
In a door or window.
In a door or a window on private property
without the consent.
It's illegal to-
And are looking in,
while you're doing it,
they are in trouble.
Yeah, yeah.
If they're on your property.
The peeping Tom thing is, again,
the peeping Tom thing obviously
is a different thing in my mind
because that's clearly just like,
an invasion of someone's privacy.
I'm talking about somebody-
If you get a good lawyer and we have 'em,
we can get off.
I'm just talk..get off?
I think if you get off
on someone watching,
then that's breaking the law.
I'm talking about maybe foreplay
and then you close the curtain.
I need to be prepared
for this conversation.
The fact that we're having an unprepared
to me makes me a little uncomfortable.
But I will say someone asked on AVO,
which is a lawyer directory.
I don't know how legit this is.
So that's my disclaimer.
I walk around my home nude sometimes.
I usually keep shades closed,
but I did not close them
and neighbor saw me naked.
I was not having sex or touching myself,
nothing sexual, just
was cooking breakfast.
And that's not a euphemism for anything.
I looked out my window and there she was.
Just feel like I'm in my own home.
I did not intend for her to see.
And one attorney answered,
a prosecutor could charge
you with indecent exposure
if someone is able to see you nude
while they are in a public place.
Don't do it.
Yeah, there's a bit of courtesy here.
I mean, maybe I'm just a live
free kind of guy, you know.
Yeah, don't do it in a way that
people can see you.
You know-
If you're doing it to exhibit,
then you're being an, then that's,
I think that crosses a line.
We recently had a friend tell us
that the idea of
being comfortable with nakedness,
and I mean, non-sexual nakedness.
I mean like roommates who
may walk around naked.
Yeah.
Was a Southern thing.
Do you remember this?
Yeah.
Did you agree with this assessment?
I didn't agree.
But I didn't want to argue it 'cause.
I think he might have a point.
You think it's a Southern
thing to be naked?
I know of multiple people
and this is gonna sound nuts, literally,
who say that growing up,
their dad would just
be naked in the house.
All right.
And I don't mean this like,
oh, going from the shower to get dressed.
I mean-
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Dad is in the living room watching sports.
That's weird.
Naked.
I'm not saying I advocate for it.
No you don't.
The only thing-
I wouldn't be your friend.
The only thing I'm advocating
for, just on the record,
is that it should be okay
to have sex in Manhattan
while you're in a hotel
with your partner on vacation
or multiple partners,
I'm not, eh, whatever you wanna do,
because people have the ability
to close the curtains on the other side.
That's the only thing
I'm man advocating for.
I want to table this as
potentially-
A whole episode?
A whole episode.
Just a minute ago, you
were uncomfortable with it.
Now you wanna do a whole episode about it.
Cause then I can be prepared
and we can get emails from people-
Lawyers.
Oh well, we can get voicemails from people
all over the place.
It's like, are you in the south?
And did your, somebody in your family,
were they like naked all the time
or was it just part of it?
Like how do you-
I think it's
just the weather.
How do you deal with
nakedness?
Just the weather.
You know, back in the day I said,
the moment of nakedness
should be minimized.
I don't know where I stand.
I gotta figure this out,
but let's hear a few more voicemails
on this subject matter.
Warning, we're getting into the poop zone.
Good.
Hi guys.
I saw your tweet about bad
neighbor horror stories.
So I wanted to tell you
about my old neighbors.
We'll call 'em Jim and Joette.
Jim and Joette had 250 pound Newfoundlands
that used to do on our
lawn pretty constantly.
And we would ask them to stop
or pick up their dogs
and they never would.
So one day on a particularly cold night
after all of their dogs
had frozen in our yard,
my dad picked up every single Newfoundland
that was in our yard
and put it in a grocery
bag on their porch.
Their dogs never in our yard again.
Wow.
Did he light it?
I love your dad.
And knock on the door.
First of all-
That's great.
Common. This is classic.
This person sounds like
they come from a place where
is not a curse word.
Like Vermont.
Or is it at least
their favorite word.
You know, I just love the way they say .
Yeah, it's very percussive.
This is great.
Do you know about these dogs?
Newfoundland dogs?
250 pounds, that's a bunch of .
Yeah, that's a big old ,
again and again and again.
But hey, I think you have a conversation.
Yeah, they didn't respond.
You gotta take it up a level.
It's like, hey here, look
at the volume of this.
Here it is. Do with it what you want.
But the thing that I don't like is
having to put signs in your yard.
Don't poop here.
Like as cute as they get,
all throughout our neighborhood
where I walk my dogs,
you know, I will clean
up my dog's dookies.
Yes.
If it's in-
And you won't do it because of a sign.
If it's in a prominent part of the yard.
You're not doing it because of a sign.
You're doing it because you're a
responsible, courteous person.
But I don't like using the bags.
So what I'll do is,
I'll usually take it
and I'll find some natural
stuff like leaves and-
What?
And rocks.
And I'll pick up the poop
using these natural elements
and then I'll throw all of that into like
a more un-landscaped area.
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
Oh, okay. No, no, no, no, man!
And then, I did it this morning.
No! No! You're part of the problem!
And then-
You're on
the wrong end of this!
You're the guy with the big dogs.
I don't leave the in someone's-
You throw it into a more landscaped area.
Not landscaped, a less landscaped area,
like a rustic area,
like a more wooded,
unkempt, un-landscaped area.
You don't know what's
going on in that area.
I mean, and sometimes I'll bury it.
What's the problem with the bags?
I don't like carrying a bag
around on my dog's walk.
It's like-
Okay, okay.
And this is what I-
No, there's a solution here.
I thought you had some
environmental issue,
like you were like,
I don't like plastic bags
and I was gonna say A,
you can get the compostable,
like biodegradable-
I have those.
Second thing is-
And I was carrying them.
I just didn't wanna use it.
You can choose to do,
there's three things that you can do.
Option number one is
what you don't wanna do,
which I don't disagree,
which is carry a warm poop bag
all the way back to your house, okay.
Then you're the .
Okay. Option number two,
which I believe is much less offensive
than what you've chosen
is option number three,
is just put it in somebody's trashcan.
There were no trashcans out.
Oh, you can always find somebody's trash.
No, uh-uh.
You can always find somebody's trashcan.
And that might lead to-
Yeah, but I'm walking around-
Uncomfortable conversation.
I'm walking around just
looking for a trash can now.
You can't put some dog in a rustic area.
You can't do that.
Some people, they're rustic areas
are their favorite parts of the yard.
Some people's children play hide and seek
and they go in the bushes.
That's the best place to hide
when you're doing a
good hide and seek game.
You got these kids
that you want to be
outside getting fresh air
and they're in their favorite hiding spot
and all of a sudden there's some
that's got some bark, leaves,
and rocks mixed in because
you tried to hide it.
Yeah.
This is the situation
that you're creating.
I hid Jade's
and then I went around the corner
and here's Jasper like in the street.
Yeah, that sounds like
something Jasper would do.
And everything around
me was too landscaped.
I think of the dog
in the middle of the
street you can leave it.
No, that's where people walk.
That's where people drive.
And so I had to resort to using the bag
and then I got to a certain point
and I said, you know what?
I'm gonna leave this bag here
'cause I know I'm coming back.
And then, but I'm not
gonna forget this bag.
You left the bag in the street?
I left the bag in a certain spot
where I knew I was gonna turn the corner
and come back home.
You did temporary litter.
Yeah, temporarily, I littered.
This is so wrong.
But I did remember it.
How about tying the bag
around your dog's collar?
So they have to deal with it.
So they'll think twice about it next time.
And it was because the trash
cans weren't out that day.
Okay.
Listen, I'm putting myself out there.
At least you don't have a Newfoundland.
Okay, so I,
this roommate is way
worse than this story is,
but this is like funny bad,
as opposed to just like holy crap bad.
Okay.
She had a cat and he was very sweet,
but she was not good
at taking care of him.
And she tried to convince us
that it was normal
that he would like to poop in the shower.
And there was nothing
we could do to stop that
other than leave two inches of water
in our bathtub at all times.
A poop pool.
We did that for a year.
It sucked. And it didn't stop him
from pooping outside the litter box
and she did nothing about it.
Ooh, that's bad.
Oh, so they put the water in there
so he would stop doing it.
Yeah.
And then you just started
pooping other places.
I think it's cool that the
cat takes a shower though.
Don't necessarily know if
that's what was happening.
Crapping in the shower.
Yeah, there's not a positive spin to this.
I mean, if that were in
our game, We're Still Good.
No, no, you can always find one.
This would actually be a good thing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
My cat poops in the shower,
but we're still good because-
I don't shower.
It's not my bathroom.
Yeah, yeah. Right, yeah.
Wow, this is interesting.
You got to have
responsibility for your pets
and you have to find a solution.
I mean, I don't have to know the solution
to know that it's your responsibility
to find the solution, period.
This is definitely a
roommate relationship ending scenario.
Yeah, if you're not solving the problem.
I think there's just something about,
one of the things that a lot
of these things have in common
is an inability to
put yourself in your roommate's shoes
and just think like, the other
person's shoes in general.
Right.
What would it be like if I was them
and their cat-
I wouldn't care about it, you know.
Was pooping everywhere.
I mean, it is a shower.
All you gotta do is take the nozzle down
and just like blast it down the drain.
Yeah, sure. And if there
are people like that,
who that's the way they think,
then you just don't be their roommate.
Let 'em live with other
people who have cats.
I haven't listened to this one yet,
but based on just like
the header above it,
I think this one gets
worse than the last one.
Hello there Rhett and Link.
This is the subject, my roommates crapped
in the middle of the room.
I was using the restroom.
We have a one restroom
apartment kind of complex.
And as I was using it,
I walked back out
and I smelled a smelly
smell that smelled smelly.
And it smelled like a fresh
deuce, to put it lightly.
And I'm like, "What's that smell?"
And he kind of looked at me and was like,
"Oh, I had to use the restroom."
And I'm like, "You had to use
the restroom, like where at?"
And he's like, "Oh, I
just did it in here."
And this is just a one
room only room, you know,
other than the bathroom that I was in.
And I like had a
horrified look on my face.
I'm like, "Where did you use it?"
And all I had to do was just look down
and I saw a towel he used
and I just was in-
Okay. This one isn't over,
but I've heard enough.
You know, I've heard enough.
I was on the edge of my seat.
I don't want to hear-
There's towel involved.
I don't want to hear anymore.
There's no way out of this. Breakup now.
Eviction, grounds for eviction.
Well, but-
Can we just go back to the cat?
I have another cat one.
Well-
Let's just forget that one even happened.
No, 'cause this is a situation, okay.
This is a situation.
You think this gets better?
I'll keep playing it.
No, no, you don't have to keep-
If you're in a place
that's got one bathroom
and two people got to at the same time,
what do you do?
Because I haven't had
this situation personally,
but I have good friends
who have had this
situation multiple times.
You don't go on the floor.
Right.
You go in something.
Well, I have-
On something.
I have one friend-
In a grocery bag.
Who was with his father
and they were in a motel situation.
They got back,
it's, you know when you've been out
and you're like with your dad
or with you're just with one other person,
you get back to the hotel room,
and you both gotta take a .
Yeah.
The older you get, the
more often this happens.
And then you gotta say,
well, who's gotta take a more,
'cause that person wins.
Right.
And sometimes it's like,
well, I gotta go more,
but you're typically a quick .
My wife faster than I do.
Let's just put it out there.
So she usually gets to go first
if we run into this situation.
Okay.
I'm just a tall man.
I think my intestines
are long or something.
But this guy got into a situation
where he won the battle,
so he's on the toilet and his dad's like,
I gotta do this.
And so he went and he
leaned over into the bathtub
and into the bathtub.
Like a cat.
Just like a cat would do.
This to me is acceptable-
Trash can.
Because you got porcelain.
You know, you're to a porcelain container
that's got water.
It's easily washable.
Yeah.
Now you're related
and so it's you seeing
your dad leaning his ass
over a edge of a bathtub is different than
you're just roommate that,
I don't know how close these people were,
but you-
And if they're Southern.
But you got like, you got trash cans.
You've got sinks.
I feel like I could pretty quickly go
through the hierarchy of where you go
after you can't get to the toilet.
And the first place is not a towel
in the living room, okay.
Yeah.
That's disqualifying.
I think you just take
their name off the lease
if they do that.
All right.
Let's wrap it up with just,
let's go back to cats.
Let's just.
Hey boys.
Hey.
I'm calling with my bad
roommate horror story.
I lived for a short period
of time with an older lady
and her two cats, who were also older.
One of them unfortunately
passed away from old age.
She was well into her twenties.
Wow.
That's an old cat.
My roommate wasn't quite sure what to do,
so she cleared all of my
food out of the refrigerator,
put her dead cat in her shoebox,
and kept it in the refrigerator
until she could figure it out.
I didn't live there for long after that.
Uh-uh!
Refrigerator or a freezer?
'Cause there is a difference.
She said fridge, man.
Hey, she cleaned the food out first.
Uh-uh.
Did it fit in a drawer?
Would you put it in the
fruit drawer or the-
The fresh drawer?
You gotta keep that thing fresh.
I think you put it in the meat drawer.
You gotta put it in the fresh drawer
until we figured it out.
She put it where the bacon goes.
Figure what out?
Am I gonna get it stuffed?
Yeah, I mean, you should've
put it in the freezer.
I just need some time to figure this out.
Oh God, this is so disturbing.
Oh.
Oh, poor, poor,
this is just a sad, sad story.
I mean, how do you, what's the,
I mean, it was in a box, but still.
But not a bag?
I know.
Cause I mean, I feel like I could be like,
I feel like if you need to
put your cat in a fridge,
first of all, put in the freezer.
Second of all, put in a bag.
Third of all-
And tie it up.
Lie about what it is.
You know what I'm saying?
Put a label on it.
What'd you put in there?
Oh, my cousin went
halibut fishing in Canada,
you know what I'm saying?
And so, yeah, I don't know
when I'm gonna get to that halibut.
There's just so many
other ways around this.
I wonder how she found out.
Did she like, where's my food?
This box and then she's
peeking in the box, you know?
That is a shocking moment.
Oh gosh, but you know, if the cat's 20
and like it's an, you know,
it's an elderly roommate.
It's like, I mean,
the older you get, the more
leeway you get with like,
refrigerating your cats.
Yeah, I mean, I don't know
how it was rectified, but.
Oh my goodness.
Is that what you want to end on?
I guess we're ending on that one, dude.
That's it. That is, man,
I'm glad that the people I live with,
I can say anything I need to say to 'em.
They can say anything
they need to say to me.
And we're pretty much, we don't align,
and agree on everything, but
oh, we can work through it.
That is the common thread.
Woo.
That is the common thread
in all these situations
we stress on a regular basis.
Communication is key.
You gotta keep those
communication lines open,
especially if somebody's
got an elderly cat.
And a propensity to place it
in the fridge after it dies.
If you're talking on a regular
basis before that happens,
then maybe it won't happen, you know.
Just keep talking to your roommates
and if your roommates won't talk to you
and they're doing weird
stuff, you know what?
Just keep an eye on that lease end date.
Uh-huh.
And figure out a new situation if you can.
All right, I got a wreck for you.
You can end with something to
listen to on your own time.
A while back I tweeted,
how did I get here?
And I put a screenshot of my Spotify
where it was just, the
lyrics were all Icelandic.
And I was listening to
this Icelandic folk, pop
and I didn't know how I got to it,
but then I realized there was some English
and it's the same artist that I tweeted
called Asgeir, Asgeir.
It's A, with some sort of symbol over it,
S G E I R.
And the song that you gotta listen to,
I'm obsessed with this
song, "King And Cross."
It's just like the way
that it transitions-
Sounds like a '90s Christian song.
Just so you know.
It's from 2013,
"His Album In The Silence."
So yeah, I've been sleeping
on this Icelandic folk guy.
Those Icelanders, they'll do some stuff.
"King And Cross" is an amazing song.
It like has this unexpected,
like, it goes into a different gear.
And the way that it does,
it's just very interesting.
We got a tempo change.
It's, yeah, it's a tempo change,
but it's like, you know,
I just love the transition
from the verse to the bridge
of this thing.
You have to listen to it to
know what I'm talking about.
"King And Cross" Asgeir.
Okay.
It's the song that I'm
obsessed with right now.
I'll have to check it
out and you will too.
Thank you for all these voicemails.
That was fun.
We're gonna keep asking
you to send us messages
and stories and you know
what you can always do?
You don't have to wait for
us to do a specific prompt.
If you've got a question, an observation,
something that you want to
say about "Ear Biscuits"
or something you'd like
to hear us talk to,
you know, talk about,
just leave a message.
We listen to 'em all.
1-888-EarPod1.
#EarBiscuits too.
See you next week.
Hi, "Ear Biscuits."
I'm staying anonymous here,
but I wanna practice this by saying,
I know that this is not
her fault in any way.
She couldn't control this.
But my freshman year of college,
I got assigned randomly to a dorm
with a girl who had
frequent night terrors.
And so she would wake up
around three in the morning,
almost every night,
screaming, bloody murder,
and would get up and run across the room.
She would go jiggle the door handle
and scream, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
And then she would just walk back to bed
and keep sleeping.
And I had to deal with that
for an entire school year.
And I know it's not her fault,
but it was a horror for me to witness.
Hello, Rhett and Link.
This is David, long time
listener, first time caller.
So I have a quick horror story
about my former roommate.
I lived with them for about seven months
and during that entire seven months,
they never once ever washed their towel
that they used for showers.
I would see them frequently
using it as a hand towel
and blowing their nose and after a shower.
So after like seven months of just months
and months of just grim
and mildew and spills,
he finally, finally, finally decided
to just throw it away
instead of washing it.
Hey, Rhett and Link.
My name is Ashley from Oregon
and my bad neighbor
story is that years ago
I slipped on the sidewalk
outside of my apartment
and injured my foot.
As I was lying there, crying in pain,
my neighbor came running out.
I thought he was going to help me,
but instead he hovered
his hands over my foot
and insisted that he was healing me.
Needless to say, it didn't work
and I actually had broken
my foot in multiple places.
Love all that you guys do. Bye.
Hey, in case you missed it,
we launched a new
collection over at sike.la.
Everything we release over there,
all the products, and apparel,
change right before your eyes.
So check it out.
And we're giving you a discount code
to use on your first visit.
Shop sike.la, drop in
"EBMADEYOULOOK" at checkout
and enjoy 10% off your whole purchase.
"EBMADEYOULOOK."
To watch more "Ear Biscuits,"
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits,"
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.